[Music]
foreign
look at what's on the front pages as
they arrive in the next half hour we'll
see what's making the headlines with the
journalist and author Christina
Patterson and the columnist for the
article Ali Mirage
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now the Metro leads
with the rescue mission at the lake in
solihull where four children fell
through the ice earlier today
that's also the top story for the
express their simple headline Lake
horror
here's the telegraph children in frozen
lake Plunge
it's also the main concern for the
mirror
the male leads with the same story the
headline there horror on the frozen lake
the eye reports there could be talks
between nurses and ministers in an
attempt to avert their possible strike
later this week
while the guardian says ministers are
Under Fire over plans to use the
military to keep some Services running
as the wave of winter strikes gets
underway
despite being knocked out of the World
Cup the sun says England football fans
won't manager Gara Southgate to stay on
until the Euros in two years time
and the star has the story of a cat who
was regarded as a lucky mascot for
England at the World Cup
and reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by Christina
Patterson and Ali Mirage welcome to both
of you let's start with the eye first of
all and the political story The strikes
that are scheduled for this week but
hopes that they could possibly be
um
stalled uh hopefully that negotiations
although they haven't been face to face
with the government that there might be
a glimmer of hope that they won't go
ahead Ali
well this is uh positive news but uh
still this just this disputes ongoing
and unless both sides sit down it's it's
unclear whether this issue can be
resolved I mean what is clear is that
Pat Cullen the General Secretary of the
Royal College of Nursing was coming out
with some really bizarre language the
other day saying that the reason why
Steve Barkley the health Minister was
not meeting with her was because she was
a woman representing a profession that
was 90 women and it had she been a man
representing a male profession she feels
that it would be very different which is
slightly odd given the fact that we've
got a strikes across the public sector
from ambulance workers to rail workers
to now postal workers as well
um so I don't think it's a sex uh issue
particularly here and I think it's
Slightly bizarre that you came out with
that look the the the rcn's Royal
College of Nursing starting point of an
increase of about anywhere between 17
and 19 is not realistic I think that
they need they realize that it's an
opening point for negation appreciation
but it's not a basis for a serious
discussion with any minister or anywhere
anyone else the reality also is that
there's an independent pay review body
that's come up with three percent now
the point here is that independent pay
review bodies are there for a reason now
three percent seems pretty unreasonable
I I think in the current environment but
so does 17 to 19 so both parties have to
sit around the table try and work
something out I think the health
secretary's been quite firm that he
doesn't want to engage in direct
discussions because of that independent
peer review review body but I think both
parties are going to have to see some
sense here and keep the talks going to
try and avert strike action well
according to the eye nurses and
ministers both say they want
negotiations uh in order to avert the
strike Christina
well according to this story yes but
there have been a number of other
stories over the weekend that have
implied that ministers are actually
refusing to sit down with nurses and the
you know they keep saying oh but the pay
review body has made its recommendations
well for a start the pay review body
only offers advice and also it made us
recommendations before everything blew
up in terms of cost of living crisis uh
soaring uh costs of energy bills and so
on so I mean nobody could possibly take
seriously
um a four percent or three percent
recommendation given that nurses have in
real terms lost
um the the RCN are arguing about four to
five thousand pounds a year in real
terms since 2010 and I do think nurses
they they have a very strong case for
industrial action they take it very
reluctantly but they have they paid the
price of covid they you know we kept
them on the streets they worked
incredibly hard in often and bearable
conditions many nurses ended up as many
healthcare workers did actually with
various forms of post-traumatic stress
disorder because it was we just have to
look back on what it was like for them
often with inadequate PP but otherwise
you know strapped up in masks and gowns
and very uncomfortable clothing for
12-hour shifts in extremely stressful
circumstances and the thanks they have
from it from this government is that
they won't even sit down with them I
think the government are playing
Hardball I agree with Ali that the uh 19
um demand is unrealistic but generally
demands are unrealistic they're a
starting point and you go down from that
point but I think the government is
trying to take kind of Macho stance and
I'm not sure how well that will go down
with the public because the public
generally I think about 65 percent of
people support nurses on this strike
they don't support all striking workers
to the same degree but generally
speaking at this point the support for
most striking workers is is higher than
the lack of support that may change but
I think the government does need to sit
down and stop pretending that it's not
that there's no room for negotiation
because of course there is well the RCN
definitely laid The Gauntlet down and
put the the ball firmly in the court of
the government by saying that you know
we're prepared to to negotiate and they
weren't even attaching a figure to that
negotiation let's move on to the Daily
telegrapher and moving on to another set
of strikes the rail strikes and we have
the transport secretary Mark Harper
saying that the the disruption means
that many people across the country will
be left with a no choice but to have a a
virtual Christmas with their their
relatives Ali
well this is miserable really I mean we
had uh a disruptive Christmas last year
when people had to do Zoom calls with
their relatives and we're looking at a
similar thing uh this year now this is
what the transport secretary is implying
here again I mean this dispute's been
going on for months now uh Mick Lynch uh
and his colleagues at the uh rmt have
got a certain amount of public support I
understand where they're coming from of
course they want to increase their pay
as Christina's alluded to it's not just
nurses but across the public sector a
lot of people feel that their real wages
have been decreasing for the past decade
so it's quite understandable that they
want to they want to take strike action
and try and do what they can however
it's the worst possible time I mean look
at the weather that we've got right now
uh we're heading for we are in the midst
of a recession if you according to the
bank of England which also might
increase interest rates this week so
this is the worst possible time uh for
this action particularly at Christmas
time which is the one period of the year
when people want to try and get together
with their family these and try and put
a very difficult period at least try and
forget about it for a few days so I also
think that the the rail unions need to
realize uh and be honest about the fact
that real practices of working practices
need to modernize and change there's 20
decrease in usage on the railways uh
since the pandemic so business as usual
is not really going to work so part of
its pay part of its working practices
but everyone needs to be sensible and
reasonable here and the government can't
be held to Ransom and the rest of us
can't also be held to Ransom because the
because the real unions are digging
their heels in I think Richie sunax is
going to be playing Hardball on this
he's already announced that he wants a
minimum threshold of service to be
introduced in legislation uh if strike
action is going to take place and in
certain areas uh really critical areas
he wants to introduce a complete ban on
strike action as well so I don't think
this story is going to end here
uh Christina the transport secretary
Mark Harper he's saying that despite uh
being offered a pay deal he's accusing
the union bosses of being ideologically
committed to Industrial action do you
think there's some truth in that
and I think I don't think they are
ideologically committed I mean remember
that when people strike they lose pay
and that is pretty tough when
everybody's struggling as much as they
are at the moment so I don't I think you
know there certainly have been plenty of
Union buses in the last 20 years or so
who have been ideologically committed I
don't personally think that Mick Lynch
is particularly ideologically committed
and in fact his board are kind of more
Hardline on um on these issues than than
he is but I do agree with Ali that
things do change and working practices
do need to change now I do think they
are not paid enough I I couldn't say
whether the pay offer they were offered
which I think was about eight percent
over two years was reasonable not it
doesn't sound wildly unreasonable to me
but I think my understanding is that the
union we're recommending that it be
turned down because of the suggestions
of Reform to working practices now
unfortunately everything has to be
reformed not well fortunately
unfortunately sound things are to do
with progress like automation of trains
I mean there are plenty of driverless
trains at the moment and they don't seem
to be putting life and limb in danger so
I I think I think there probably does
have to be a bit of give and take here I
think the government's Hardline stance
is unhelpful
um I don't think the nurses are being
Hardline I think they are being
conciliatory
um I'm not getting quite the same
impression from
um the rail workers and as Ali says this
will be absolutely miserable for so many
people broadly I support I broadly I
support most of strikes at the moment
because I think people are not seeing
their pay increase in line with
inflation and the cost of living but I
do also think this is really going to
make life miserable for so many people I
was just in touch with a friend just
before this program started who's having
colleagues to stay this week because
they can't even get home to their
families because of the rail strikes
Christina we must leave it there for the
for the moment Christine and Ali thank
you so much we are going to take a break
and coming up I think it's all over but
is it we'll look at Garrett's
southgate's efforts to boost the
nation's morale that's coming up next
[Music]
you're watching the Press preview still
with me Christina Patterson and Ali
Mirage Alou come to you first in in this
section and this story in the guardian
really talking about the implications of
the government using military cover for
for the strikes and obviously Personnel
will have to not have their their
Christmas breaks and military sources
are saying that officers are warning
about the potential impact of the morale
on troops who've also seen declining
real terms pay
I think that's right did you know if
you've got a problem yeah the first
lever you reach for is the military
where the military can't be a Panacea to
every strike that's going to be taking
place I mean good for them for stepping
up there's going to be a cobra meeting
that's going to be held tomorrow to
discuss the implications of military
personnel getting involved the thousand
of them are being earmarked to do this
at border staff driving ambulances and
other things along with uh civil
servants a thousand civil servants and
also volunteers so look it's not an
ideal solution but the country's got to
be kept moving in some way and if you've
got a problem you call in the military
because they are the experts they always
step up for their country and they are
logistically on top of things but you
can't use that you have to use it
sparingly and as it says the guardian uh
point there it's making the point that
these uh military personnel have also
suffered real terms pay cut so they
can't exactly be too happy either but
you know come athia cometh the Army uh
to step up and uh and help keep the
country uh on the straight narrow yeah
and as you say that first Cobra meeting
will take place tomorrow let's move on
to the Metro Christina and their story
about strep a test
um selling out extremely worrying uh for
for parents of children in that age
bracket
yeah I mean the strap a whole Japanese
phenomenon is horrific for parents and
my heart I'm not a parent but my heart
goes out to them having had now nearly
three years of covid to have this uh
this infection apparently it's spreading
so fast so being so virulent and
tragically having killed I think about
15 children by now success the thing is
that
how terrible
um these tests are not necessarily
reliable though
um and uh the we uh have been assured by
the NHS that they're now are many more
supplies of antibiotics so the important
thing of course is to get to a doctor or
to contact
um the the NHS phone line if your child
is ill but uh obviously a very very
worrying time and awful for the NHS as
well to have this on top of all the
other pressures it faces at the moment
Ali the swab kits apparently are
changing hands for more than a hundred
pounds
um that that's according to the Observer
but their accuracy is uncertain so the
advice still is to get a diagnosis from
a GP
that's right and you've got an increase
in cases here that's been caused by the
fact that we were in lockdown and
understandably in lockdown I'm not a
lockdown skeptic I I understood why we
were in lockdown but obviously you're
going to have kids that have not built
up immunity during that period and
that's where you're having an increase
uh in strep a and obviously parents have
to be and parents are clearly very
worried at the moment are going to have
to be looking out for signs of uh rash
and and other things so that they can
act very quickly I mean there apparently
there is also in certain areas a
shortage of antibiotics although that's
being denied by the government who's
saying that uh Supply chains are working
effectively but it's also being reported
uh in the Metro that amoxicillin is
running short in particular particularly
in parts of Cheshire so look it's not an
ideal situation but parents need to be
mindful and Vigilant and take Swift
action where required absolutely now we
couldn't finish the paper review without
talking about the football and the son
is saying despite England coming home
early
um fans at sea teams still want Gareth
Southgate to continue in his role
Christina
Garrett's I love I'm not a football fan
I would like Gary Southgate to resign
from his job and run the country instead
such a decent nice man he's so sensible
he listens to people he has such great
integrity and of course you know it's
very sadly Harry Kane unfortunately
apparently left and let the country down
but I don't think that's an unforgivable
sin and I think it's just that kind of
steady moderate approach that's
Collegiate building team spirit that we
could do with the country and we've had
so little of in recent years from this
ghastly government and its predecessors
so
um obviously I am no expert on football
tactics but what he has very evidently
done is built a team that has great
loyalty to each other great competence
some great players and I hope he stays
and that's from someone who's not a
football fanat Ali do you think he
should stay
yeah I do think he should I I Echo what
Christina says I do think he's decent I
think he's really built uh Team morale
camaraderie he's built a great Squad I
think he was personally quite wounded uh
in June by that defeat to Hungry
four-nil defeat and the reaction that
the fans gave him I mean obviously
people were very upset about the result
but they really rounded on Southgate and
I don't think he's forgotten that and
look being an England manager there's
nowhere to hide takes an impact on your
or your personal uh toll on your health
and your and probably time spent with
family so he's got to spend a bit of
time deciding what he wants to do his
contract's up in 2024 we hope that he
takes us through to the next Euros
um but it's a personal decision for him
I mean frankly the others being
potentially lined up I don't think
anyone is better than self-care and I
think he's done really really well and I
think they also played very well last
night I mean the margins are very fine
at the top level International Football
and we feel for Harry Kane you know he
tried his best and these things happen
he did they all did they all did Ali and
Christina thank you so much